This video represents a hundred percent
fact,
and it's not at all an opinion.
If you disagree with this video,
this merely implies that you are
misaligned with reality or miseducated
on the facts.
If the former,
I suggested psychiatrist the latter,
I suggest watching this video.
Let's start this up.
The piano is the greatest sytropin ever,
and I'm going to give you five reasons
why.
Number one,
most instruments like the voice,
wind,
and brass instruments can only play one
note at a time.
This means to even play simple pieces.
These instruments require you to have
several friends to play with.
With piano,
you can forego all of that in play,
several notes at the same time,
which is one of the main reasons.
It's the most popular singles
instrument.
I mean,
solo instrument number two,
a lot of instruments take a ton of
practice just to create a good sound
like trumpet or Violin,
which leads everyone with an earshot to
hate you.
Why you practice?
Yeah,
with just one press of the Canada,
anyone can get a reasonable sound.
Okay,
so even though the piano is incredibly
tough to master,
at least people won't hate you while you
do it.
Number three,
the layout is intuitive.
Now,
I know this might sound confusing to
some of you who look at the piano like I
might look at Chinese menu,
but trust me compared to some of these
monstrosities,
the piano is really easy to understand.
All you really have to know is the pitch
of these notes go up in ascending order,
low to high.
What's your brain expects is exactly how
it's laid out.
This is always higher than anything
below it.
Add to this the fact that the piano is a
very visual instrument and this makes it
the perfect learning tool.
This is why if you seriously study any
instrument,
you will at some point be asked to pick
up a little bit of piano on the side in
order to help you understand music.
Period.
Number four,
whether it be Chopin,
Bach,
or billy Joel,
the overwhelming majority of great
composers play piano.
Number five,
check this out,
Huh?
Now that's a pretty compelling reason to
learn sacks,
but
actually it was played on a keyboard.
Okay.
A an electric piano using
call instrument.
These are becoming more common in some
more realistic as technology gets
better.
So eventually you'll be able to play any
instrument from the greatest instrument
of all the piano check mate.
But now that I'm done ripping on every
other musician,
let me just save this.
I'll hope for you guys is not lost less
pianists have one crucial,
yeah,
there it is.